I'm the kind of person that believes you
should always make decisions with your
heart and soul the Y comes before the
how the Y is the heart the head is the
how most of the time if I follow my
heart and everything else will fall in
place rise and shine it's an spresso
time good morning believe nation it
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so grab your
coffee and sip on today's message follow
your heart
over to you Mel Robbins I'm the kind of
person that believes you should always
make decisions with your heart and soul
you can use your brain for math you can
use your brain to look at the fine print
and a contract but when it comes to the
actual feel of the decision you always
want to go inward and check it against
your heart and soul how do you do that
here's the simple test does the decision
that you're about to make expand you
expand your future or expand the
possibilities of your life if the answer
is yes then the decision is yes no
matter how terrifying it is if you
conversely look at the choice that you
have to make and the decision will
shrink you will silence you will inhibit
you in some way then the answer is no no
matter how easy the decision is no
matter how safe the decision is the
answer is no now one of the things I
want to point out that when you start to
use this does it expand or does it
shrink me does it open possibilities or
does it keep things closed does it raise
my voice or does it silence me right is
that there's always a short-term and a
long-term impact to the decision the
short-term impact to making an expansive
decision a decision that's based in your
heart in your soul
sometimes it's terrifying because
sometimes it means Moo
or it means changing a job or changing a
relationship or having a difficult
conversation or starting something new
and those sorts of things are always
uncomfortable so brace for impact
put the force fields up but make the
decision anyway because the long-term
impact of making a decision from your
heart and soul that is where the best
life comes from because you're living
for what's true for you not what's safe
in the moment you should make the big
decisions in your life and in your
business with your heart and the small
ones with your head big decisions with
the heart small decisions with your head
why the head can only understand a world
that currently exists it's the logical
world it's the practical world but
unless you would just want to be a
photocopy of somebody else then you need
to make the decision with your heart
because your heart can create something
new created something that hasn't
existed before comes from a place of
passion not from a place in your head
and so you need to decide whether you
want to live a unique life or not if all
you want to be is a photocopy of
somebody else then use your head forever
in your life for every major decision
that you ever have to make and you'll
just be a junior version of somebody
else but if you want to create an
extraordinary life you want to create a
life on your terms you want to create
something amazing as an entrepreneur as
a father or a mother or a husband or
wife then you have to make the big
decisions with your heart I look at my
youtube channel as an example first even
the decision to get into YouTube needs
to be one from the heart that you love
making videos that you love be able to
spread a message I love helping
entrepreneurs I love it I get energy
from it it fuels me it's not a practical
thing for me I would do it even if I
wasn't making any money and at the start
I wasn't at the start I had three people
show up to a free event and I was making
no money and I thought I would never
make money doing this I thought no big
company is ever gonna pay me to come in
and speak because I'll tell they're
people that go beyond Trinette know
entrepreneurs gonna be able to pay me
because entrepreneur starting up don't
have a lot of money so how will I ever
make money off of this I won't but it's
okay because I love and I have to find a
way to keep going and that led me
eventually into YouTube I love making
videos
boom the share message with you guys I
love waking up and seeing the comments
that come in and knowing that is having
a big impact so the decision to get into
YouTube was based off of the heart even
the decision to make certain kinds of
videos is still coming from the heart I
strongly believe in modeling success I
love it I love being surrounded by
people who've accomplished big things it
forces and stretches me to want to do
bigger things myself when I watch videos
of Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel
Robbins and makes me want to strive to
do more and I think that's a great thing
and I want to share that with you guys I
make my videos self with you for myself
and I share it with you guys then the
head comes in to help optimize
everything the head is what am I going
to call this video what's going to be on
my thumbnail what's the intro and Extro
going to look like what clips are we
going to use how are we going to do
special effects on the videos to make it
as good as possible so it's always both
you need the heart and the head working
together but the heart makes the big
decisions the head then helps you figure
out the how the why comes before the how
the why is the heart the head is the how
I hate it when people make pros and cons
lists should I marry this person or not
well what are the pros and the cons you
can write down the list right and Demi
only be one thing on the Pro and 10
things on the cons you don't say no
because there's 10 things on the cons
and one thing on the pro and maybe on
the cons list is they live in a
different country or they speak a
different language or they have
different you know religious and
cultural backgrounds or whatever it is
on that list and there's only one thing
on the pro and that's that you love that
person don't marry them and you can
figure everything else out your brain
can come up with an answer for
everything else that's on the negative
list in every single big decision that
you ever have to make in your life or
your business please make it with your
heart it's scary it's impractical it's
illogical it'll be the decision that
your friends and your family and the
people around you tell you is crazy to
do but if you're feeling it then you
have to do it otherwise you risk living
the rest of your life in regret big
decisions with the heart small ones with
had always now I've got some special
bonus clips for you but before that my
question of the day is I want to know
what was the last big decision that you
made with your heart I want to get
inspired leave it down in the comments
below I look forward to hearing what you
have to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
enjoy the bonus clips and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso
[Music]
what is it about investment and
entrepreneurship that sort of has bitten
you I've never looked at it as
investments believe it or not I'm just
look at it as partnerships help changing
the world and just being part of
something that's inspiring my business
people out of time whenever they talk
about money you're gonna ask the mother
guy I don't want to hear it but if they
bring an idea to me and I think it's
gonna go to the next level most of the
time if I follow my heart and everything
else will fall in place I've never ever
done a deal and we got this suit company
we throw some pinstripes in the suit you
give me out a thousand we sell 20 of
them we make I've never did a deal where
it was always based on money
I've always did my business deals better
I felt it was going to go in the future
I felt it was gonna help and inspire
somebody people that I look up to and
admire it's not anything physically
different between them and me it's just
the way that they think when I was able
to realize that it was a mindset thing
that mental constructs and breaking them
down and habits and all these things
were able to be rearranged and you could
literally rebuild the way that you
thought to be the type of person that
you want to be and achieve the type of
goals you want to achieve that's when
our life changed yeah because I realized
that it really was all the way that I
was thinking sometimes you close doors
to yourself that you didn't even know
we're always open you literally put the
door in knob and the handle and the key
on them when they never were there and
once I realized that I was like the sky
really is the limit like it really is
the limit but you know it's not to go
biblical but it's like you know as I
walk through the valley of the shadow of
death I shall fear no evil for them I
you know I mean you know what I'm
talking about
yeah that is the mind that is the valley
of the shadow of death the thoughts that
people the things that people say to you
that we rotating your mind the things
you see on on who you look like you know
that is a big thing you watch TV is
showing you see a blonde and they're
supposed to be stupid am i stupid
yeah ignore if you see a person a black
person and they're belligerent am I
supposed to be belligerent those are the
things that aren't that that isn't you
your mind is like a computer and it's
just playing back in itself what it's
already seen that's why you have to
follow your heart your heart it may not
know how things are gonna happen but it
feels it so if you follow that
that's where you end up where it is
you'll be able to really manifest what
it is your dreams are because your mind
doesn't know because it hasn't seen them
yet you're the one that's supposed to
deliver it to the world your first work
it was a television job I think it's
Rosanne is that correct oh yeah that was
my first job
so was was that did you always want to
do television I know that you come from
a television family or did you did you
go out to Hollywood to work in film or
television how did that work I would
never do television I was that was
beneath me I studied film and my bad my
best friend senior year used to taunt me
you're gonna be a third generation
television writer 3g TV you call me that
all the time
and then I you know I got out to
Hollywood and discovered incredible lack
of money and so I started poking my nose
around and then realized oh there's some
very good television that's being made
and and as soon as I started writing it
was really the first writing I'd ever
done over my television specs that I
wrote trying to get a job and and that's
when I fell in love with writing was
through television so and I had the
privilege to work on Roseanne which was
you know he of the best show on and it
really it had a level of reality that no
other show was really busting out just
then if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details